yeah welcome to this video it's some
dual commentary again against um my
friend Brandon here the good night on
icc and it's BTR 7 3 186 on youtube i
post the link to his own comentary also
we got a french defence i played one
year form ok let's start like this i'm
not quite sure what kind of lines is
playing Knight c3 and now black of
course has some moves Knight to f6 I
always believed that if I've must be
critical here not Bishop g5 but alright
so matter of taste I guess so we got
them the main line here of the classical
French the Steinitz variation there
should be three it's normal and here
again black has a huge choice he can
take on deform on twin B 6 a-6 Bishop e7
there's a huge choice am let's see what
he comes up with Quinn b6 hmm yeah this
can get very tricky I don't know what
what lines is he plays okay i need to go
night a for this is so the first thing
not much else and then see 3 yeah here
black has some couple of moves can play
see txt for which is answered by before
and it gets very tactical before yeah
yeah blacks may move now is taking on
before with a night sacrificing a piece
there's also Quincy seven but this is
not so well-regarded rather passive hey
he obviously doesn't know the line okay
so what now should I okay I cannot take
with the poor now because before us
hanging still um this may be some point
in taking with the bishop it would
fortify the center nicely but Knight
takes d4 looks like the normal move mmm
yeah sometimes they're their tricks on
c3 in this kind of kind of position but
that don't see don't see anything here
so just take with the night there are
similar positions where black has a pawn
on a six instead of a knight on c6 for
example then you can play b5 and c3 is
hanging but it shouldn't be am an issue
here yeah this is some queenside
expansion here with c3 mp4s of course
the bit double-edged i wint space and i
take away the c5 square which is nice
cannot put anything on c5 but it's also
a bit weakening need to be cautious it
can be a problem in the long run yeah
what should like do probably just Bishop
e7
seven castles look some normal now you
cannot go f6 because it six is hanging
oh this is so good I'm not sure Bishop
d3 young where does this belong I am
usually d3 is so just the right place
for the bishop yeah I guess I can also
think about a three supporting this
pawns could be it could be an idea so
that after night XD for I could even
recapture with the pawn but a 3-wood
would help to make the queenside a bit
more secure yeah but probably I want to
Castle first and then play a 3some it's
the kind of decision where you can spend
quite some time on the few if you have
the time but we're playing a 10-10 game
so 10 minutes and 10 second increment
the allison in icc terms of standard
rating this is also why i'm on 2009
brandon is on 2036 he just played games
I didn't so I still have the default
rating of 2,000 ok a 6 is an interesting
move may be intending be five so maybe
now it's the time to play a 3 yeah on b5
icans I can go to be too he takes on d4f
the choice i can even take with a porn
queen c3 community to its kind o problem
so yeah b5 is a move black and play of
course idea being also Knight b6 to see
form
I can play a photo he goes b5 I can play
a photo to play against the b5 pawn gap
black can also simply cancel here ok
let's just check quickly if I've got
anything else now now I need to retreat
no problem so now it cancels me
interesting yeah should I play a 4 or
should i cancel first don't know how to
tell also and I don't know maybe yeah a
foursome a bit more aggressive obviously
pretty much forces him to take the only
problem could be some weird tactical
some tactical shots like a four-night
see take c5 it's probably not working
but need to check this out see txt 5ft x
g5 Queen takes you three check 22 and
then Bishop before sometimes sometimes
stuff like that is really working he
then threatened squint XP too and now
this line is some most likely complete
nonsense but yeah I can cancel whatever
I don't want to deal with that
it's probably probably not working but
my position should be a-ok in any case I
shouldn't I mean I don't need to rush
things here black doesn't have so much
that you can do we can play the night to
see for which I just capture and it's
not the end of the world for white but
still a foursome a good plan 11 point of
f words of course is that it makes some
sense of the b-29 which is some gear
somewhat wheatley placed so I could play
it now if I she takes two times and then
then might go be should be seven
shouldn't be too bad for black
yeah but how is this position if you
take if you place 94 94 or f6 f6 is now
a possibility as he six now is covered
yeah okay well let's let's look at a
phone again if this is really bringing
anything good if you would take two
times and Bishop e7 is this may I it
still should be something for what a
six-pound sm is weak so I'm not liking
it so much I don't know
how how to improve otherwise I could
play Queen h5 also provoking g6 and then
drop the Queen back maybe to f3 this
would be playing more on them on the
garlic inside and how to decide okay
let's let's play that probably a force
of the strategically a cleaner move I'm
sorry the idea of placing the Queen on f
three years let it fly to see for I can
take and he cannot really capture with
the deep on as some c6 is hanging or a
eight if he chooses to UM trade first on
deform
yeah Bob like him can also just play we
should be seven now wouldn't be too bad
for him and yeah probably a four was
right I can also take on now on d4 know
simply then play Bishop be 70 okay I'm
taking with the pawn I don't like Quincy
three evils maybe maybe just good okay
take it the bishop this also helps to
against f6 this was also an idea of
Queen h5 this is g6 move now it is very
difficult for him to UM to think about
g6 okay so what about a for now mmm yeah
I can probably still just take it all
night see 494 even but not see if I
could could actually just ignore Queenie
too I should have gone to eat too now
not to have three this was probably
probably better yeah should I go away
for now mmm-hmm how to tell I mean I
have I don't think I have any realistic
chances of of playing on the Kings side
oh wait wait wait wait
I'm just spotting an idea what about f5
just directly opening it up f5 GF Bishop
takes GF Queen g3 check king age 86 wins
the Queen huh nice hmm of course this is
some yeah a bit of a corporation line
like it's not obliged to take two times
still it looks fun hmm ah come on I
didn't calculate this too too too too
deep now but it looks like fun let's try
this night c4 also an issue which I
should have paid more attention to but
let's see for what could i do all night
c4 I can't play f6 I mean F successor
looks a bit silly maybe because uh yeah
you don't want to close lines but what
what would plug answer might be too
takes on his heaven looks a very grim
and if you would remove the bishop to d8
I just need to get the Queen on h6 that
it's really made mmm tricky and so light
c4 looks like him the move to play I
cannot really capture on c4 and I takes
he takes c4 and then the queen is
attacked and also the bishop of course
on d3 yeah and I must submit that f5 I
mean it was a bit tempted by this nice
Queen winning a line but okay
it shouldn't be terrible okay when night
c 4 m naught c 4 really is the move hmm
what what can i play all night c 4 h mm
can protect protect me the night of
course the move like rook f2 or
something but it looks so this looks
passive yeah i have six young as
mentioned i okay took it okay this is
different now fifth of course so i can
just take it right on night c4 then i
can i can then even capture yeah with a
fine position okay and let's just check
quickly that i'm not seeing complete
nonsense here GF queen g3 check King
edge 86 wins the Queen right yeah it
does win the Queen okay so while I
managed to open up the F half which is
not bad at all um but I'm not
threatening anything yet I don't think
black is in terrible shape would be
surprised if that this would be the case
and but it can get ugly very quickly
have some some rather cook strengthening
ideas here i can bring the night queen
93 f for something I can just get player
sometimes just play six and then crash
through the bishop on defaults of course
a potentially very strong piece and of
course this is the reason why this is
working at all with their five
yeah what should like to editors this is
11 defensive move i considered it's not
not bad probably tries to get rid of the
strong bishop so is their way to not
exchange it I mean Rick changes wrong
word up obviously I don't take on see a
dialysis nonsense move but I mean to to
not move it yeah this is the right
expression to move likely six for
example but it doesn't really am work
you can just take it all right so I need
to be to retreat this piece to mc2
probably to see two so that 93 sm
possibility ok this is you played
quickly an ID 32 c to f ym this is the
the normal way to yeah come on um okay
look you got Bishop f5 maybe this
initial who could be
mmm [ __ ] with a five or seven hmm not
sure I play Queen g3 threatening the
exchange psyche ok can I don't have all
day here time time is getting I'm
getting lower slow night at four looks
like oh like a move he needs to pay
attention pay attention to yeah I m92 we
are yeah I don't know maybe I can can
even ignore that the night looks like
like the only piece of that he has the
tips doing anything I'm dumb maybe I can
really ignore it and the sacrifice
exchange here it's probably not bad just
go nite f4 for example 94-92 Quincy
three and then h4 h5 it's quite
dangerous but okay if I just turn I just
cover this yeah looks like it looks like
a good move just prevent 92 and I mean
what what should like do now a5 here
maybe a five the only way to get some
counter play
yeah if you look at the times always
take into account that this is 10 second
increments so it's no problem at all at
the end to to win if you're pure simple
yeah if you've got some extra material
are very easy winning position then you
will manage so it's not so dramatic as
it looks this two minutes are two
minutes something from for black here
yeah lonely counterplay so just even
pileup him all this stuff is hmm nicely
protected oh I just blundered a 3 this
is bad I always thought you would I
would just take and what about a 30 wow
this is bad and this is also um yeah
rook f2 then was was really bad yeah it
can get very tricky oh this is good
night a three I don't know what I would
have played even there should be three
maybe but daya this is now fine again he
really needs to take on a three this is
probably good for black
yeah this should be fine again if I got
like two moves and Quincy 394 then it's
basically over I mean this is too much
on the king don't believe her like Anna
blackened keeper keep the position then
Quincy 394 applet it's a bit too lazy
maybe maybe not a force better just
ignoring the night a threesum that's
real nuisance don't know maybe I'm
mostly evaluating this position not
correctly it's possible that black still
was okay or maybe I met this I can't
believe I mean this is just a just a
strong attack maybe 9 a-3 now I'm coming
hmm night III mmm but I can play should
be three all night a three right it's
not too too terrible so let's continue
with them with the general idea neither
for immediately might be able to take
you five so I don't want to play Knight
f4 in sub D this is yeah okay I need to
go here now and then it probably needs
to exchange yep so rook takes probably
so 9f 495 I can take you six senses not
working but this must be right the night
is good on air for taking d5 and damn
preparing nasty stuff on g6 yeah okay
but wait 95 what about 95 95 55 e6 the
same idea again me6 mmm okay I'm not
quite sure if you just can you can play
Queen move but I have Knight f6 then
yeah okay this must be fine Knight f6
ours looks good I can simply take yeah
of course I can also just take it seven
and then Bishop situ or something just
continue with with the brilliant
position yeah
oops did overlook something no don't
this one the Queen hey I hope I didn't
make a silly blunder here no I don't
know just it just overlook this with a
little time on the clock que habla
blacks falling a partner also besides
the Queen down I def 67 alts hanging
black resigns yeah this was a was son
was so easy if you would have taken on a
three I think I'm pretty much busted
really I completely overlook this look
here in this position black takes now I
can't play here but this wasn't planned
I mean it's probably not lost or
anything outright but I simply
overlooked at this point is saying so um
he really needs to do that I mean
probably no here and and then and I
continue to attack I mean it's not it's
not an easy one for black but he must do
this I mean objectively it's probably
very good for him but some so needs to
be played but I simply overlook this I
mean to sound until here I'm very much
okay again this whole black should be M
should be tenable yeah and an
alternative as mentioned was on 190 I
move like a move like immediately night
f4 simply because this is really some
compensation this is this is dangerous
for black I'm on I'm on g6
on e6 I mean ideas like taking here
taking on g6 any combination of this and
of course this stuff night h5 this is
this is clearly compensation for the
exchange um yeah I should have done that
maybe he need us need to take but it's
probably it's stronger than this is what
I would have played okay so let's let's
look look at how the game progressed
quickly yeah yeah this is still fairly
solid for black I mean it looks looks
nice for white but let's say it place
normal oof I know look here or something
not not not clear that I have anything
anything spectacular like threatening
this move no yeah it's still probably
okay I like white but it's not not easy
to get anything real and this just a lot
not destroy the stroke here let's check
quickly if he doesn't take here
Heidegger completely overlooked I can
also go here and this is curtains
immediately winning the the exchange
here and still you to tech on top of its
not like just an exchange alright yeah
ok then then then this is really
completely completely dead and okay yeah
good good thing that I had this idea
earlier with the night if this six
winning the Queen so that I can spot it
that's what I did it here alright yeah
thanks for watching also make sure to
watch um yeah Brandon's version of the
game the link will be in the description
and most likely also on a clickable note
if this is working in YouTube they had
some problems recently with this yeah
thanks for watching